I hate celebrity endorsements and let me
just say I've got two that I really am
furious about first of all Adam Levine
has a line of clothing that he designed
for women at Kmart okay is that true oh
my it's all under the pretense of like
oh if I wear this Adam Levine would me
but it's more like oh he'd spit on you
and they're like we'll take it you know
like it's like hey marks and then the
Kardashians have a line of clothes at
Sears yeah which I'm positive I don't
even think that's malicious I don't even
think they know that they have it like I
think there's no way they know what
Sears is you know this is how I think
that deal went down and they're victims
I feel like someone came to them and was
like girls do you want to do a clothing
line for Sears and they just thought
first years was short for four seriously
[Laughter]
[Applause]
Cheers yeah sign here so that's my
theory
oh my god absolutely you're absolutely
hilarious I love it when you come on
this I love you so much both of you I
just have to say like I you're the your
this show is the reason I do stand-up
I've never been able to say it on air to
you but I've told you a million times I
am obsessed with you no and you thank
you but like I've just I I watched your
I watched your five year anniversary
special on YouTube the other day I had
it memorized
and then they were playing the role
before the thing that shows all the
clips and I was just I I I knew it all
and I love you and so I think this is
like a make-a-wish for me I'm dying well
if it got me those compliments I don't
care
you